-You know, before the show,
Jamie and I were talking about
some of our favorite '90s
R&B groups.
And we got reminiscing
about this duo
that we both loved,
named Take Two.
If you don't remember Take Two,
they were this an R&B duo
who were famous
for doing the flirty dialogue
at the beginning of R&B songs.
But here's the thing --
they never actually
got to the singing part.
[ Laughter ]
They only did the talking
at the start.
Well, I just found this
old commercial for their music.
Check this out.
[ Applause ]
-The R&B box set you've been
waiting for is finally here.
It's "The Complete Take Two."
This special collector's edition
includes all
your Take Two favorites,
like their number-two
smash hit, "Hey Girl."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Hey, girl.
-It's been a long time.
-But lately,
you've been on my mind.
♪♪
-So, tonight, I wanted
to tell you how special you are.
-That's right. And it goes
a little something like --
Well, there's actually
are a couple of things
I want to tell you.
[ Laughter ]
-First and foremost,
how special you are.
-Yeah, right!
We'll cover that.
But, also, I wanted to tell you
that you make me feel,
you make me feel,
you make me feel...
-Good.
-You make me feel good,
I guess is the point, right?
That's -- And I get --
Also, that I get
a little nervous sometimes.
You make me a little nervous.
-And I never met anyone
like you before.
-I mean --
[ Clears throat ]
I mean, I've met
women before, of course.
I mean, I've met women who are
orthodontists like you are,
but -- but my current
orthodontist, she's a woman.
-But you're the only one
in my mouth.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
You the only one that floats
down my root canal.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
♪♪
-[ Laughs ]
You talkin' about the girl
we're singing about?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Her! Oh, yes, yes, yes!
-Oh, yeah, perfect.
No, of course.
-This set has every Take Two
every song ever recorded.
Well, maybe they're more just
intros than actual songs,
but they're still smooth.
Like their 1993 classic,
"Hey Girl, We Good?"
♪♪
-Hey, girl, we good?
[ Laughter ]
-♪ It's been a while
since you've been around ♪
-♪ And at night,
I've been missing you ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-It goes like this.
I recently moved, so my mail
is still all messed up.
So, you know how that goes.
You -- You got to get
a forwarding address.
It's a whole thing.
-Yeah, and I've been getting --
I've been getting mail
from alumni Purdue.
And I ain't even go to Purdue.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Now, usually I just leave that
in the mailbox,
let the postal worker
take it back.
You know, but some--
but sometimes it's --
Mm.
-Ooh, sometimes...
-Sometimes I flip through them.
♪ I-I just flip through them ♪
-Flip.
-I'm like a flip.
-♪ Flip ♪
-♪ I got a little finger flip ♪
-♪ Why don't you flip? ♪
-♪ Finger flip through,
the Purdue University book ♪
♪♪
-I just saw that
Orville Redenbacher
used to go Purdue.
Did you know that?
-Wait a minute.
That's the popcorn dude?
-Yeah, that's the popcorn
with the bow tie.
-Neat.
[ Laughter ]
-Like holiday songs?
How about holiday intros?
'Cause we've got all
of Take Two's seasonal hits,
including
"Hey Girl, It's Halloween."
♪♪
-Don't worry, baby.
I will hold you close
when we watch a scary movie.
-Oh, I like scary movies.
Do you, girl?
Well, uh -- huh?
-How about -- How about --
What movies are you discussing?
Really scary or...?
-Any type of movie you want to
talk about, my vanilla friend.
♪♪
-How about scary movies
like "Jaws"?
-"Jaws," yes!
Well, "Jaws" isn't technically
a scary movie, because that's
not really for Halloween.
-Well, it is a scary movie.
If you watch it in October,
I guess that makes it
a Halloween movie.
-"Jaws" literally takes place
on the 4th of July.
[ Laughter ]
That is the complete opposite
of Halloween.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I always --
[ Laughter ]
I always thought the opposite of
Halloween was Valentine's Day.
Sort of different ends
of the love-fear spectrum
kind of, you know?
-Okay, I'll give you that.
But still, it's not Halloween.
There's no line
in the "Monster Mash" like,
"Here comes Jaws, the shark."
[ Laughter ]
-Pretty sure
his name is just Jaws,
Not Jaws, the shark.
-I swear to God.
-Oh, no, man.
-Plus, this set
is loaded with rare,
never-before-heard
Take Two jams.
♪♪
-Hey, girl.
It takes dos.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh!
Exhale.
That was our original name,
-It takes two.
-And that's us.
-Yep.
I was just trying to corner
the Latin market with "dos."
-Oh, I understood.
I understood.
-[ Speaking Spanish ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Muy bien. Gracias.
We certainly have not run...
♪♪
...out of flirty R&B intros...
talk, or anything like that.
If you're thinkin' --
Get it, get it, get it.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, you know what
I was thinking?
-What?
-One, because we are Part Two...
-Yeah.
-...why don't we sing
a little something for them?
What do you think?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Just this once.
-Just this once.
And by "it" -- by "it,
do you mean singing?
-Yeah.
Correct.
Yes. Yes, let's give it
to 'em like --
give it to 'em like...
♪ Ye-a-a-a-a-a-a-ah ♪
-[ High-pitched vocalizing ]
-♪ Ooh, baby ♪
-♪ A-a-a-a-a-a-a-ah ♪
-♪ What, what, what, what ♪
-♪ Oooooooooohh ♪
♪ Oooh, oooh ooh ♪
-♪ Wednesday, Thurs, Tuesday ♪
♪ Wednesday, Thursday ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Order now.
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
-Jaime Foxx, everybody.
Stick around.
More with Jamie after the break.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Jimmy Fallon in this house!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday,
Thursday, Friday, Saturday ♪
-♪ No, no ♪
-♪ Sunday, Sunday ♪